season over it's like and you you
started like I think you really start to
think of like what you really just did
so not just not just that 16 games it's
like all right we had preseason games
yeah camp that we just went through we
had OTA is he was training like it's a
whole like snowball effect you know all
that physical work that you just put in
and it's like throughout the season
sometimes you don't realize how hurt you
are how it's hard you are you just going
going going like when the season ends
like I think like the next 2-3 days I
was like knocked out at Salva camara he
was with us at the Superbowl last week
talking about the 17 game regular season
that the NFL wants and the way it stands
right now big cat the NFL and the NFLPA
negotiating teams have reached a
proposal that is being presented to the
NFL PA for consideration that would
include 17 games in the regular season
on a 10-year CBA and it's they're
getting more pushback than I think they
thought they were gonna get from NFL PA
leadership yet you negotiate with the
league and then you have to sell it to
your client and it's a complicated
process because you've got an executive
committee a board of player
representatives and then eventually a
full vote of the union and they're
having a hard time getting leadership to
sign off on this cba premise taun 17
games the players don't want it I think
it's it's even less attractive to
players in the month after a season
ended maybe later in the offseason
they'll feel better about 17 because
they will have forgotten how bad they
hurt
after 16 what's your thought generally
on 17 I mean I feel like it's inevitable
so I've accepted it and the fact the
union is negotiating based on 17 hey if
you don't want 17 you tell them from the
get-go
we're wasting our time talking about 17
games but they've negotiated for a year
I feel like it's inevitable do you want
it to happen okay so explain to me real
quick if there are 17 games season there
will be two buys is that correct no no
that the structure would still be won by
I have some people would like to buys
that would push the Super Bowl to
President's Day weekend but it would
still be won by that's what I go for so
I agree with the players when they say a
17 game season like why are we adding
another game it's already a long enough
season give me two buys and give me a
Super Bowl a Presidents Day weekend I'm
all
for that because what from from my
perspective and this is the total fan
perspective all I want is to bridge the
gap a little bit more between the Super
Bowl and March Madness that's all I want
that's all I want I want there to be as
few weeks between those two events as
possible so give me 17 weeks
give me two byes let me watch week 17 of
the NFL season or week 18 whenever you
want to call no to be week 19 right with
two byes let me watch that in January
let me watch the playoffs starting
mid-january get me all the way to
Presidents Day weekend boom now you have
Monday off after the Super Bowl
everyone's problems are solved when the
issue of 17 games first emerged as the
compromise between 16 and 18 last July
Packers CEO Mark Murphy spoke about it
at the annual shareholders meeting for
the Packers organization and I got
Murphy on the phone after this all
started to come out and he told me that
the networks don't want to buys they did
two buys in 1993 if you recall back when
you were what eight years old eight
years and it dilutes the schedule when
you add that second buy think about it
you're taking more games out of every
week think about what a nightmare it
would be for fantasy football with two
buys for every team and how many teams
would be off in any given week
III know you don't care and you like to
scoff but a lot of people care a lot of
people care about that so I think I
think that logistically it makes I head
well let's just add another week but you
add another week by taking games away
and you already lose those four to six
teams every week during buy season now
you're gonna make that even worse big
cat Mike I've said this idea before I
think you're the one who was like that's
the craziest idea ever throw it out but
I'll I'll do I'll repeat it again do two
buys and one of those weeks make it no
football on that Sunday give everyone a
reset day where they can you know be a
good husband be a good dad be a good
wife whatever it may be
give everyone that one day where they
can sit down on a Sunday be like you
know what I'm gonna see
my family again football his family give
me a reset day a reset week everyone's
on the buy maybe throw some college
football games on that Saturday give me
that and you solve everything I say play
Monday move them to the Sunday I know I
don't despise it
I don't despise it it's like the
Mother's Day for NASCAR they always shut
down on Mother's Day right you don't
give me give me the regular all right
okay here's what I do here's what you do
you give me the regular buy schedule and
then say the week the season goes all
the way to January 15th or whatever it
may be
give me the Sunday closest to Christmas
because those are already Bowl games so
you can let the bowl games happen it's
already you know family time you want to
spend time with your family you're not
gonna want to watch you know the
Saturday night game something that game
give me that one week off so everyone
can go spend time with their family and
then give me three weeks of football NFL
football on the other side of Christmas
to finish out the season there it is I
just solved all the world's problems I
may have hated it the last time around I
don't hate it this time but I'll tell
you what the audience on Twitter hates
the idea of 17 games I put the question
out yesterday very simple do you want a
17 game regular season yes or no more
than 50,000 votes and there's totally is
time to vote if you have it 62.2% don't
want 17 games I didn't vote no on that
somebody vote yeah I did yes I voted yes
like you vote is only know somebody I
think I think it had somebody had to
vote yes or no to get the the final
numbers I did not vote no because I
here's a thing it's inevitable I've
accepted it and what the union is gonna
negotiate on 17 games they've accepted
it too the question is how much money
they're gonna get for it give your
Christmas off that is a great bargaining
chip to get that seventeenth game and
you won't miss it that much on Christmas
right around Christmas if you can watch
bowl games and you can go spend time
with your family you won't miss NFL as
much
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports